in a time before many can remember I
already know I'm gonna hate this movie a
warlord named piccolo came from beyond
the star
it's not a fucking warlord named piccolo
who would decide to keep that name evil
pear brought the human race to the brink
of annihilation evil brings human race
to the brink of annihilation cliche a
group of brave warriors created the
Mathu ba a powerful enchantment that
imprisoned piccolo deep within the earth
and decreed a powerful enchantment that
would have killed this asshole why can't
things kill things in these movies also
let's not only imprison him but put him
deep in the earth say hello to parallax
and the black goo from Thor the dark
world asshole his master captured
disappeared
even though Piccolo's henchman is
supposedly badass in his own right he
decided to just vanish instead of
finishing off a weakened human race
something tells me this will be the
opposite of evolution like we might not
be able to stand completely upright
after this movie first rule is there are
no rules you CGI sweat is CGI also slow
motion sweat montage I'm not saying I
don't appreciate a good SWAT the fly
into your grandfather's mouth scene
occasionally but I don't feel like this
movie has earned my trust enough to get
away with one so early apparently the
first rule is that there are no rules
about looking totally stupid either
random ass watermelons are nearby so
that falling into them is funny you rely
too heavily on your external senses your
eyes can deceive you don't trust them am
i right
true power inside your ki he is the key
maker so I guess Goku is learning from
the right person this area got
landscaped during the goku grandfather
fight because now there's a shrub and
greenery that was not there before seven
dragonballs will grant the holder one
perfect wish if I had the seven
dragonballs I would wish that movies
never again mentioned artifacts that are
spread around the world and only work
when they're collected though ku parks
his bike in a huge car space which means
Goku is a dick to his high school and we
all know where this is going also the
popular kid straight up try to murder
Goku did you just fart that person no
the screenwriter just wrote something me
we pain keko keko fuller gives goku a
free shot to the left side his face
which would be great for a right-handed
punch but goku clenches his left fist
for some reason I mean hot babes
currently banging Fuller's show up just
in time to humiliate Goku even further
top babe who's going out with the school
asshole actually really likes the
protagonist cliche I guess this is an
invisible ship and no one who watches
this guys for a living ever notices it
also what happened to the powerful spell
that sent piccolo deep into the earth
did construction workers accidentally
dig him up trying to build a McDonald's
just because the wood creaks this chick
gets suspicious about people under the
floor
holy shit its Sinestro also is there a
reason why he needed to show up at this
very moment other than the dramatic
reveal also they dragged poor James
Marsters into this didn't they go whose
fantasy involves strawberries but not
nudity nobody fantasizes in a classroom
and gets away with it oh my god
ancestors say what they might say no
wonder American kids don't learn
anything in school like grandfather
would say beware than iMix oh so that's
why the teacher asked such a stupid
question
so we could get some exposition on some
bullshit they're an alien race they're
nearly destroyed earth over 2,000 years
ago surely it's more than that right I
know we're in a fictional universe but
wouldn't there be evidence of this event
if it only happened 2,000 years ago
though Goku couldn't use his key with
his grandfather ask the power of boners
is stronger
the girl he's interested in just happens
to know everything about this cable that
Goku takes the Dragonball to chi Chi's
party for no reason other than the plot
geez Goku didn't even tell his
grandfather he was going to the hot
chicks party seems like an unreasonable
dick move considering he's so important
to him all the popular assholes from
school decided to party outside the
entrance to the mansion so that this
fight could happen pouring water on the
ground is awfully intimidating it'll be
a massacre I knew these guys aren't
smart but I thought everyone knew that a
massacre involves killing lots of people
so even if you destroy Goku into
millions of pieces it's still not a
massacre house move might have been
impressive if the bully didn't scream
trying to punch him slow-mo overkill
bowling after all those kids got knocked
out trying to murder Goku the party
continued and the unconscious kids in
need of medical attention were left
lying in the driveway
I like different that's why I dated the
school's most popular asshole that's
perfect timing because she's 26 why did
you bring ninja stars to fight the old
man but a sci-fi gun to shoot the lady
in the Japanese village it's not here if
he knows the Dragonball isn't here just
by feeling it then why did they even
bother going to the house it's to kill
the grandfather and make Goku feel bad
for being a dick isn't it also father
figure dies after the child was a dick
to him cliche and he could have just
done this in the first place why does he
need any henchmen also with this kind of
power who needs Dragon Balls something's
wrong
the moon and the Dragonball know when
Goku's grandfather is about to die for
some reason didn't piccolo just crush
this house why isn't the whole house
just a bundle of sticks and debris right
now I mean come on
piccolo has just about the same
detection power as our on at this point
and do piccolo not know about Gohan's
grandson it could have just waited here
until he came back and he could have
taken the Dragonball later find out this
is a nursery rhyme why a story like this
was passed down as a nursery rhyme and
not something important is total
bullshit this quest could have started a
long time ago when there would have been
no issue
Hausa United where is it I know it's
here motherf King pronoun game also they
drank poor emmy rossum into this didn't
they are you piccolo did you not listen
to your grandfather
he definitely referred to piccolo as a
he just before he died my new this job
will require a jet pack at some point
luckily for her this highly secured
phone has a skylight nearby I followed a
signal here and that's when I ran into
there are seven dragonballs how do you
only get one signal how do you know I
had the Dragonball a little machine I
invented oh good because when Goku's
grandfather said he was gonna have to
find all these things I thought he was
gonna have to go on an adventure or
something thank God that's not the case
also since she didn't know there was
more than one Dragonball when she came
here did she invent this machine to
track the one Dragonball in her father's
vault just in case it got stolen and if
so why didn't the machine tell her of
the other Dragon Balls sooner and she
definitely didn't build this thing
overnight either I'm gonna make them an
unlimited source of energy then I'll
turn into Doctor Octopus and spider-man
will have to stop me this is less
believable than the invisible car James
Bond drove in that die another day both
is
how do you know the real question is how
does Bowman know that Goku is referring
to his dead grandfather Dragon Ball
detector is just now detecting the
presence of another Dragon Ball is this
the same house mal hit her totem in an
inception yeah because that huge golden
ball crashing down on the table wasn't
noisy at all just because it's in muted
slow motion doesn't mean it didn't make
noise they dragged poor chow yun-fat
into this didn't they also they were
just looking for Roshi and here's Roshi
I thought it might take an adventure of
some sort to find him I sure I'm glad
that's not true sure little crazy strike
I recognized that anywhere wait is a
shadow crane strike such an exclusive
move that it absolutely has to be the
work of go Han I trained it huh go in is
way older than Roshi
unless Roshi is supposed to be one of
these Wolverine types who never ages
seriously guys this is like watching
Robert DeNiro in Rocky and Bullwinkle I
just can't believe what I'm seeing and
come to believe me I tried forever to
unlock Sheng long and Street Fighter 2
and that did not go well if the prophecy
is true can't we just have a sci-fi
fantasy martial arts picture without a
king prophecies for once seriously who
creates these prophecies anyway an
entire body of water disappears and no
one sees it or reports it much easier to
fund without the water this asshole can
detect a straight Dragon Ball under the
water but still didn't know where the
hell Goku's Dragon Ball was earlier
share a strike it's the most basic of
all the airbending pay but I could still
tell you we're using go hands particular
shadow crane strike for some reason even
though it is very common also did we
have to bring airbending into this isn't
that a completely different anime I'm no
expert but pretty sure that airbending
is something else also movie forces me
to remember the last airbender I know
Roshi said he needed to become stronger
but this is an unnecessary dick move and
geez it looks like he's physically fit
enough to run this far with hundreds of
pounds on his back without even breaking
a sweat
I doubt he really needed to get stronger
if that's the case and well it still
should be even if you blind about this
place how many people would actually
want to make the trick to train here
Goku's would-be girlfriend just happens
to be whaling on some dude at a remote
martial arts training park when Goku
walks up
haha that is funny another Wilhelm bites
the dust' also this guy is practicing
his moves on top of the rock in this
shot but in the next he practiced
something disappearing because that
asshole is gone yes I'm like that hey
what was it that you wanted to tell me
he was an old man and his death barely
affected me at all girls are pretty
where did this asshole get a coke
Mikey's shriveling up oh maybe ki really
does have something to do with penis at
least this won't be a total waste I got
a signal from a Dragonball yeah Dragon
Balls are just everywhere they go aren't
they also this device only detects them
when they need to get the hell out of a
scene that's pretty convenient I'm
getting a strong signal from a
Dragonball only three miles I mean for
the update we heard that 40 seconds ago
in fishing racket how many people drive
down this country road and fall into
this trap this is a bad way to make
money you have some no marshmallows but
I do have a story ironic that a
character in this movie has a story but
the movie so far doesn't 2,000 years ago
damn it he's rehashing the movies
opening narration intuitive the Blood
Moon will eclipse the Sun he wasted a
lot of time back when they were at
Roshi's he said they had seven days in
seven days the Sun will be eclipsed by
the Blood Moon then they decided to go
way out to this martial arts nature
place which must have taken five days
because boma discovered a signal and
they fell into the hole shortly after
gathering Dragon Balls was the priority
but they wasted a whole week trying to
give Goku some training he didn't really
need also if it took him five days to
get to one place that means chichi and
Goku are in some serious trouble at
school that or they're on spring break
or something unless we find the
dragonballs
and you saw wish to banish piccolo Lee
please the goal is to banish piccolo
from the earth how did that work last
time again oh yeah it didn't Dragon
Balls close I think it's buried
underground because that's something
your little device can tell you he
couldn't done this earlier I wasted even
more time because this asshole wanted to
tell the story we already heard at the
beginning
[Music]
luckily they were captured by a friendly
bandit with those very tools I guess yes
robbed us wouldn't be able to get this
dragon he states explicitly how stupid
that is
I followed muten roshi as directed he's
training the bullies well if you call
running around with something heavy on
your back training yeah give it life
what life well primordial jelly is just
lying around waiting for Piccolo's blood
to infuse life into it this volcanic
wasteland is apparently
where they were riding the motorcycle
earlier how does a Dragon Ball end up
here perfectly sitting on this volcano
crag wait there's an army of these
things Mia said his blood would give it
life sounding like one singular being
but there's a whole army here's the
underworld school of movie fighting on
full display all we know is that asses
are kicked into the lava it's a good
thing you have a table around then thank
you bridge even better their dead bodies
form a perfect bridge you need to cross
the lava goku punches my and she falls
into the pit of characters the
protagonist forgets about for no reason
he will destroy everything the futures
always changing this is a fox movie and
i think some of the pages of the star
wars trilogy that mixed up with this one
on the way to the copier what's a
harmless ball touching between Bros
clips is in two days we'll never find
the other dragonballs in time you're
just now figuring this out Doris and all
the way to stop piccolo why bother
wasting 45 minutes a time telling us
these Dragon Balls are the only most
important thing and then say no there's
another way okay the only chance the
whoa test now is hidden toys hey that's
exactly where chichi said that fighting
tournaments gonna be they dragged poor
Ernie Hudson into this didn't they evil
henchmen has time to enter a fighting
tournament just so she can steal chi
Chi's blood also it's pretty amazing
they were conveniently paired together
in order for this to happen
Goku somehow shows up right after my
leaves the arena I could enjoy talking
to a pure random guy enters the picture
he gets to nail emmy rossum you can't
have a business-minded hot girl who
doesn't want to date that's nonsense
all the things that have ever stopped
people from kissing in movies this is
perhaps the dumbest and most welcome my
grandpa always said in order to master
my king I have to be a one with myself
and with my enemy silliman what that
means I'm pretty sure your grandpa
didn't know what that meant either every
time you light a torch you get to take
one step closer to me I'm so certain you
want to bone me you'll be shooting ki
like it's a tantric money shot you've
been holding in for weeks once again
even though Goku's mind could not figure
out the key the power of boners is
stronger also is this being at one with
yourself aunt take one step back three
more
also mine has got to be the clumsiest
ninja I've ever heard because those who
can light three lanterns in one move
should get laid no matter what there are
a bunch of people sleeping in this
temple but wait a minute that noise is
totally suspicious also mine has got to
be the clumsiest ninja I've ever heard
how did my know to transform into Chi
Chi all she knew from the volcano scene
was that Goku and crew were going to
toys on because she was listening from
that thing
even if she somehow saw Goku and chichi
in the secret martial arts place it
takes a huge leap to say I remember that
girl chichi and she's gonna be in that
fighting tournament I better hightail it
down there and enter because then I can
steal their blood transform into her and
no one will ask questions when I go into
the temple also how she wearing the
exact same outfit that the real chichi
is I mean I could accept the blood
transforming thing but where does she
get this exact outfit in a pinch when
there isn't a gap anywhere in sight
for Goku could use the fire
extinguishing thing we just saw him use
about two minutes ago he bolts for this
stupid and the real chichi says nothing
in protest this guy is way way bigger
than the one she actually got at the
tournament o villain weapon that we just
saw create a huge fire a minute ago
changes to let's keep the hero alive
mode there's no real rush to change back
into yourself really but there's
definitely no real reason to change back
just outside the room where there are
people we need to kill you it's not your
time Goku it's not your time cliche I
have the how how do I defeat oozaru
always have faith in who you are
thanks grandpa I'll be sure to faith
that monster to death also why are you
so concerned about is aru it's in
piccolo the main badass in this movie
that was my hell for 2,000 powerful
spells that send you deep into the earth
let you free without explanation hope
you're not trying to impress me oh my
how can this gas battle go any farther
when he had this thing going past 180
miles an hour why didn't you just do
this in the first place
crash-landing threw a giant rock and a
flying Humvee brings no harm to our
heroes whatsoever I've just been in a
horrible accident better get into my
yellow outfit and shit
Roshi fell out of the Humvee landed on
Hard Rock's and then slammed by falling
rocks
this adventure presents no real danger
to anyone except those who watch it
there witness to my glory when I compel
Shen long grab me the power to rule
disease Rock I pretty much already have
that power now but I decided I needed to
get a magic Keeney dragon to really make
it work when the Blood Moon eclipses the
Sun you will be common sorry
here's another whammy surprise that
doesn't make one bit of sense I don't
know anything about dragon ball and I'm
pretty sure there's it's all over the
Dragon Ball universe also this is a
ridiculously convoluted plan
I feel like oozaru could have lived in
the Pacific Northwest as Bigfoot and
that would have made more sense than
transforming into a baby who only
reverts to his true form 18 years later
but only if there's a solar eclipse also
why did piccolo and his henchmen try to
kill Goku so many times in this movie if
he was that important and why do people
who make prophecies not see something
like this you traveled by meteor to hi
the most of Burma who exactly set the
meteor into motion making sure it landed
in the right spot especially when
piccolo was in prison deep beneath the
earth whoever did this and to make sure
it landed precisely 18 years before
piccolo would be set free something that
was impossible to predict and still
hasn't been explained at some point this
movie just needs to give me a fucking
break
powerful ma Fubon tornado still allows
its captor to conjure magic while
ensnared in it Tashi let me help you
saying things the awful bad guy who once
was good can be reasoned with and turned
back into a good person cliche Oh
sovereign can't beat this how about a
nuclear bomb good anything to feed him
before he had this stupid idea to turn
into a meteor baby because I'm still
scratching my head about the meteor baby
it's possible agreed this movie just ran
with that didn't it wait mm okay I can't
quite figure out what's wrong with this
scene but maybe it's because it looks
fake ish it's Megan Bob it's Mike your
mistake was talking also this guy
survived through sheer movie editing
when we last saw him he was getting
pummeled by Zaru we didn't see the whole
fight so he survived because fuck you
that's why to be a one with myself I
must be too yeah but that was about
mastering your key inche didn't have
anything to do with this other nonsense
I wish it didn't have to
when someone says something about this
movie not ending I get nervous
my god which requires a ceremony also
why did piccolo have to wait until the
solar eclipse to make his wish but Goku
can make a wish any damn time he pleases
the Dragon Balls are gone we have to
find them again what kind of bullshit is
that
also this movie thought it was gonna get
a sequel I just have to do one thing
Goku refers to chichi is a thing
relationship
you basically just met how is this a
relationship right now
discount rocky 3 showing the main title
again reeks of desperation and refunds
movie we long ago walked out on as a
bonus scene during the credits queue a
movie
[Music]
normally we never do this we never refer
to the original material when we come up
with sins for a movie and for the main
sins video we kept to that philosophy
however considering that Dragonball
Evolution is one of the most requested
sand videos we've ever had we decided to
do some research just this once don't
ever get used to it we take you to the
things that pissed off the fans of
Dragon Ball bonus wrong Goku's hair what
happened to Goku's power pole open the
story of you some serious power bowling
action and Oh chichi does doesn't go
hand a famous martial artist and this is
just an old dude who know some moves
things have gotten better at go hands
residents as their small Hut has turned
into a large house on some large
plantation of some sort where's Goku's
best friend Crillon i guess it can't be
a lonely teenager if you have even one
friend in the movie Goku only cares
about fitting in at school and not
becoming a crazy fighting badass but
turned my into a humorless killer I
thought my worked for Emperor pilaf oh
well not enough room for two big
villains in this movie seriously no
antenna what's up with school anyway
isn't one of the big things about Goku
is that he doesn't have much of an
education the only time this asshole
ever wants to hone his keys when chi
Chi's around and this guy didn't really
even like Chi Chi in the manga although
if she look like Jamie Chung that would
have turned things around this what we
didn't have the balls to have Goku as
the great eight step on and kill his own
grandfather Ouma has blue and purple
hair right not just one silly streak of
blue hair uh so she knows way more about
the Dragon Balls than she does in the
movie what was up with that Ouma is
definitely no fighter but the movie
would have you believe that she is her
wish was to have a boyfriend not money
and fame we actually would have given
credit
the movie for that change but then she
falls in love with mantra for no reason
when the movie Roshi is not bald and
looks way younger than go hand his
suppose its student in the effort to
keep a PG movie row she's perversions
are kept in check jeongja also wants to
make money with these Dragon Balls not
cure his shyness of course this asshole
is in no way shy in the movie look at
what this motherfucker is wearing in the
movie piccolo creates minions using
blood not eggs also whereas kids
tambourine and cymbal and drum Dante is
a major fighter character turned into
comic relief in this movie also wears
his sword in the movie Rosie's master is
Sifu Norris when it's really master
bowtie too also Russia never doubted
Piccolo's existence calling the
Kamehameha airbending Goku is such a
badass in the original material he
didn't need boners to pull off the
kamehameha he just did it because that's
what Goku does Ola is quick to pull that
gun out isn't she she should be way more
hesitant Mike and shape-shift the
kamehameha brings Goku back to life even
though it has no healing properties
whatsoever in the movie piccolo wants to
rule the world or something but not
become young again now we know why this
is really stupid
Goku came to earth in a spacecraft in
the manga and in this he comes to be a
meteor which of course is dumb as hell
remember when I said this scene probably
all over the Dragon Ball series here are
the reasons it's wrong transformation in
the movie requires no tail mazaru is way
smaller than the great ape that goku can
turn into the great ape is turned into a
character named whose aru and works for
piccolo who has no affiliation with
great apes a solar eclipse makes the
transformation possible rather than the
moon the mokuba is a total pussy in this
movie I never dies in the series but
evil always has to be punished in the
movie Goku easily defeats the normally
extremely tough piccolo in this movie
yep I thought this was stupid he can
only be summoned by this dumb
incantation beikoku
whereas usually just yelling out his
name would do the trick Shenron is a big
character and he gets no speaking lines
just grants a wish and then disappears
and finally the Dragon Balls don't turn
to stone in this movie also they just
get lost rather than being unable to be
used for a year which makes way more
sense than this bullet
[Music]
it's over nine so listen why don't you
turn around walk away no even know you
were here
are you deaf McFly beat it no Biff you
leave her alone why you're asking for it
[Music]
watch uses heavenly stuff that you stick
forever
my name is Neil yes how the key-maker at
the lane field you Boris you're found a
way to make the time pass up dear
[Music]
something my grandfather taught me you
do not talk about Fight Club I like
children for breakfast
never I'm a lot dragon my name is Falcon